touch the microphone it makes a weird
noise everybody welcome to Columbia
University's College of Dental Medicine
our class day this is a very special
moment I want to welcome all the parents
the important others family friends and
particularly this truly excellent class
of 2010 to this special moment I think
this is the the high point of four years
in many ways because this is our
opportunity as a faculty with the
support of numerous organizations to
recognize the excellence that exists in
our student body this class in
particular if you are an award recipient
you are special when this class entered
this institution you had the highest dat
dental aptitude test scores in the
history of the school as you are going
out the door you have the highest
percentage of classmates who have
attained a match particularly in a
specialty fifty percent 38 of 76 of the
people in this class have matched
specialty programs that is also an
institutional record that you have
attained so in spite of us beating on
you for all four years one way or
another you have been very special and
we very much appreciate the
professionalism and the caring that you
have shown for your patience and for us
the faculty while you were students here
pausing for this important moment is
very important and we're happy to do it
with you in fact it was the wisdom of
our Dean and yes teens and half wisdom
the wisdom of our dean IRB Lamster to
separate this from the diplomas ceremony
so that each in its own unique way is
recognized as the major achievement it
is and that's why we do it this way at
this time without saying much more i
would like to introduce the Dean of the
College of Dental Medicine dr. our
appeal answer
well good good afternoon and it's really
a pleasure for me to welcome all of you
here today this time of year is
wonderful because it's filled with many
very important events and clearly
graduation is specifically what I'm
referring to this really is a rite of
passage traditionally here at the
college this had been divided up really
into two ceremonies the first was the
college graduation which will occur on
Monday morning and then the university
graduation which will occur on Tuesday
morning as you heard dr. Davis say we
decided to break off this ceremony as
something different so what we'll do
next week is really celebrate collective
achievement and what we're doing here
today is celebrating individual
achievement the curriculum here at the
College of Dental Medicine is very
demanding and all of the individuals who
are going to be called to the podium I
think should be celebrated by us all for
what they've been able to achieve let me
just come in just very briefly about
these sorts of events these are the sort
of times these are the sort of events i
think that stay with you stay with all
of us for a lifetime in some ways you
remember the day you were married you
remember the day you have your child
your children but you also will remember
your your college and your dental school
graduation and certainly these
ceremonies we certainly hope you enjoy
the next three or four days before they
really are very special so my
congratulations to all of you who are
receiving awards and certainly
congratulations to all of the family
members who are here to celebrate with
us thank
now I'd like to bring up someone who has
been special to all of you as was
special to me as one of my earliest and
frankly most demanding professors and
that has not changed one iota our vice
dean for academic affairs dr. Letty mas
allenton I want to wish you a very
hearty welcome and glad to see you all
and I really every time when this
happens I say you have arrived in 2006
and for you it was for it long years you
finally made it and when you look at my
perspective you say it is very different
I look at you and said are you already
qualified to graduate okay all right a
silly seriously now I know you are and
these have been some intense years for
you you have a gained a lot of knowledge
you have got a master an enormous number
of facts you have become competent in
many clinical procedures and you have
become a member of the dental profession
in the sense of being a true
professional and that's quite an
achievement to do that all in four years
is pretty darn good congratulations to
all of you and enjoy this particular
event
there are two individuals who you will
hear from today they were selected by
the class and they represent this class
and have done some special ways the
first is dr. david alfaro who has served
them as their student government
president david please come
Dean's Lamster marsala time faculty and
administration family and friends and of
course my fellow classmates thank you
for being here today as we celebrate the
many achievements of the class of 2010
it's hard to believe that for years of
past and here we find ourselves marking
the conclusion of one journey and the
beginning of another each of our lives
had different courses and directions and
we all arrived here in separate ways but
for these brief past four years we have
battled it out together in these
infamous lecture halls and clinic floors
now we sit as one for one of the last
few times in a chance to recall
everything we've been through regardless
of how we arrived here each of our
relationships with Columbia began the
same way with an interview day where we
had the opportunity to mingle with
potential classmates professors and
administration it was then where I'm
sure many of you decided that Columbia
was the place for you to begin the next
stage of your life my interview was an
excellent experience I was hanging with
Mikey and Sam and dr. McManus was just
joking with everybody at the table I
thought to myself can it really be is
everyone here as outgoing and that I
continued off to meet with dr. Mitchell
and dr. Jenkins and I was sold columbia
university was where I wanted to attend
dental school now we know that the
College of Dental Medicine has a
reputation of excellence we all know
about how awesome we are and how great
our scores are and how many great
residents we graduate and so on and so
forth but it all begins with admissions
the admission staff has done an amazing
job of selecting the finest students
with the best personalities this is
demonstrated in the achievements we all
have obtained as a class but more
importantly it's reflected in our class
dynamic it's imperative that the
attention to the selection process
continues even without dr. McManus at
the helm his departure is truly a great
loss to this institution but we all wish
dr. McMahon as the best in his new
endeavor at the ad a i'm not going to
chronologically recap our last four
years because they're permanently seared
our brains we have fought Claude and
battle their way through these tough for
years and here we stand victorious as a
group proudly receiving the awards that
we have merited while we would all like
to think that we did it ourselves and we
have earned these amazing results mainly
due to hard work and perseverance our
successes would not have been possible
without the tremendous mentorship that
we have received from day one at
Columbia we have had the great fortune
of learning from leaders in academic and
clinical dentistry dr. Moss 17
exemplifies everything that a true
educator should be she set the standard
of expectation for our class and set the
bar for the quality of instruction that
students at Columbia deserve dr. you on
he made learning fun and taught and
lived with an energy matched by no one
even though he's no longer with us his
memory and spirit will be carried on in
each and every one of us who were wise
enough to take his wisdom in oh and
there's dr. hood avi he's not here today
is he he of the golden handpiece while
we slaved away with hatchets and chisels
and burnt ivory teeth to a crisp with
him peering over our shoulders at our
soup bowls and our swimming pool
preparations many of us feared his
criticism but he taught us how to crawl
and then how to walk in a manner that
would even make GV black proud in the
clinic there are too many amazing
faculty to faculty members to be named
individually again we've been truly
blessed to work with you and it is taken
for granted how hard you work to provide
the highest quality dental education
possible the best faculty members
expected more out of us than clinically
acceptable while it's frustrating at
times to have to redo an impression or
to send back a crown because the margin
was a open a fraction of a millimeter it
was all in the pursuit of excellence
during one night clinic I was walking
with the professor to show her my
restoration and she asked me how I
thought oh look I said clinically
acceptable another professor overheard
and said to me clinically acceptable is
not acceptable
you are better than that and she was
right we are better than that in looking
back at my education at Columbia I do
have to say that the except the
excellence expected of its students must
saturate all aspects of the educational
process we've received an amazing
education but in the spirit of those who
taught me best there's always something
that can be fixed it would have been
ideal to spend all of my time learning
from the amazing faculty we have but I
guess sometimes we have to spend it
looking for a torque wrench or PVS or
trying to find out exactly how we're
going to get out of here we can all
agree that these are minor
inconveniences but this is an Ivy League
institution and we are Ivy League
students and expect nothing short of
excellence just as it is expected of us
we've seen the improvements over the
past four years and I know that the
lessons that we've learned as a class
and as an institution will lead to an
even better flawless experience for
those to come remember clinically
acceptable is not acceptable class of
2010 I know these are going to sign like
closing remarks instead of opening
remarks when when I would arrived in New
York with honor cohen-chang cheetah I
had no idea what to expect all I knew
was that Washington Heights was hot busy
at dirty but right from orientation I
realized that I had begun something
special I'm proud to have been educated
at such a storied institution but now as
we finish up I'm even prouder to have
completed my education with you guys
we've been through a lot we become the
best of friends in the hardest and most
stressful of climates and I can only
hope that the end of our dds does not
mark the end of our friendships the best
memories I will have of New York will
not be of the Empire State or the
Brooklyn Bridge there will be a putting
my napkin in the air seeing Carlo
performed his first extraction which
happened to be on a 256 bird that was
stuck in Joey's head watching Scott
consume more red bull and the human
kidney can possibly process and all of
the endless pleasant experiences we
shared both
academic and social I want to thank you
for giving me this opportunity because
to me the recognition of my peers and
friends is one of the highest honors
achievable I know that we were already
will enter residency in full stride and
will once again rise to the top of our
respective programs I hope that the
future brings you all the success and
happiness you deserve and I can truly
say that getting to know in each and
every one of you has done nothing but
make me a better person class of 2010
let me I tell you I'm going to miss you
and I wish you the best of luck in the
future thank you very much
now you see why they picked him as their
student government president as well
with that we will now move on to the
actual presentation of the awards to
this class these awards are selected by
in certain cases if their divisional
excellence and that's what we call our
departments divisions they are selected
by that division if it is a general
award of merit or achievement it is
selected by the entire fourth year last
committee all of the course directors in
that year so these these awards are
consensus awards at some level I'd like
to it at this time bring up dr. Moss
Valentine again
I am standing in awe of the person that
I'm about to give an award it is very
rare to find somebody who almost every
course honors and in her case she in
fact had honors for every nine out of
ten courses which is absolutely
incredible and I am truly impressed I
would like to call up Mary ballot
a pleasure to have with us today an
individual that is the president of the
new york academy of dentistry an
organization which is designed to
recognize professionalism and to
encourage the interaction of us in the
profession here in the new york area the
president of that organization is here
to present an award dr. Henry Calvin
thank you I'm very pleased and honored
to be here today on behalf of the new
york academy of dentistry is Marty dr.
Davis I said we are in the organization
that has always stood for the highest
levels of ethics and professionalism and
as such we are very proud to be able to
present this award for exemplary
Professional Conduct every year the
concept of professionalism is a very
very complex one and many books have
been written about it and and articles
have been published about it and they're
people who talk about professionalism
for hours so for someone to have
distinguished himself at such and such
an early part of his career to exemplify
this type of professional behavior is
quite remarkable for many of us this is
something that we're professionalism is
cultivated over a period of many years
with the help of mentors and role models
and such so I'd like to present this
award and call abducted Jeremy's and
either
it should be very very proud to receive
this award and in addition I see you
also received an award for clinical
excellence as well so the whole package
is serving the type of individual that
we would love to see in our Academy one
day so I wish you the very best of luck
graduation to all of you at this time
again I'd like to bring forth Dean
Lamster who has several presentations
Thank You Marty I actually have a
pleasure of making four awards the first
three I'll begin with and then we'll
take a little break the first award is
the ella marie you will award for
distinguished service to fellow students
the individual who wins who has been
selected for this honor is the current
president of the SGA I won't go through
his resume and all that he's
accomplished but I think you can see by
the remarks he just made wise very
deserving of this david alfaro
thank you next award is the College of
Dental Medicine Leadership Award and
this is presented to a student who
demonstrates exemplary leadership
throughout his years at CDM this
individual was president of the American
Student Dental Association record
Student Association from two thousand
seven to two thousand eight again his
extracurricular activities are too
numerous to mention he will be
graduating on Tuesday actually with two
degrees a dental degree from the College
of Dental Medicine as well as an NBA
from the business school in looking over
his record and some of the comments that
have been made about about the student
he was described as having great
integrity being very accomplished being
very caring it's a pleasure for me to
present this to Wayne Stevens
I also have the honor of presenting
their research excellence award the
student who was selected by the fourth
year class committee for this award
actually won first place at the hinman
symposium competition in which dental
students from all over the country come
together and they share their science
but they actually compete for an award
and this student won first place a few
years back for a work that he did with
dr. shreek olahraga van and the title of
his presentation was identification of
beta 6 interpreting cytoplasmic domain
interacting proteins Armando rotana
I just want to once you indulge me for a
second I'm going to ask two groups of
students to stand these two groups of
students have already received their
awards at special occasions but the
thing I'm asking you to help me with now
if there are eight of them in this first
group which is the Omicron kappa epsilon
essentially the Phi Beta Kappa of dental
school the top seven or eight students
in a class if they're eight of them
let's see x 200 IQ points each that's
1600 isn't it I'd like to show you about
1600 IQ points now would you please rise
when I call out your name as a member of
ok you David Alfaro Marielle Ballard
we're at the park chan
moving beyond flowing
and her family tion hick Kim
Ryan Turner
yeah Kimberly bet the solo money
and Scott Jacen Solo congratulations
from all of us thank you 30 years ago
this year we began a very special event
with help of the New York State Dental
Association now its foundation in honor
of Percy T Phillips who was a Columbia
Graduate who was also a president of the
New York State Dental Association who
was also a president of the ABA and a
very staunch defender of Education and
the practitioner together a combination
that wish we had more of as part of
honoring him we annually have a visiting
professor come here for two days present
a memorial lecture and then we have two
students scholars selected from eight
candidates and those two scholars do
their own presentation from the body of
work of the visiting professor and those
presentations are published in our new
york state metal drum I'd like to
recognize the two people in this class
who served in that capacity and did a
superb job as per CT Phillips student
Scholars David Alfaro stand up with they
don't recognize you
on Nicole Madison lever
thank you and congratulations again I'd
like to call the Dean back up for a very
special award to a third-year the only
one in this group you know I forgot to
mention psycho haha I think we're very
fortunate here to have many many
excellent many excellent students and
one of the true assets of this dental
school are it's trainees so I want to
congratulate you all again and not only
do we have excellent fourth-year
students who are presenting awards
through today but we also have excellent
30 or students and second year students
in first year students however at this
event we only present one award to a
third year student and that's the new
york state dental foundation dean's
award and as listed in the program its
third year student who demonstrates
academic accomplishment committed
service and membership in the American
student Dental Association the person
who was chosen for this award is going
to be the president the American student
Dental Association in the 10 11 years so
not only did we have the president of
the american student association for
0708 we're also having that that a
columbia dental student hold that
position for for 10 11 there's a lot to
tell you about the awardee let me just
say that not only has a demonstrated
commitment to organize dentistry but his
academic performance has been
outstanding and I'm really here in two
capacities I serve as a board member for
the New York State Dental Foundation
also obviously is the mean it's a
pleasure for me to present this to
Corwin hockey
congratulations I just said to Dean lamp
sure I don't think you know I've been
around at this a while I'm here awards
that nice let alone the money that's in
that envelope its flight it's
frightening Corwin congratulations at
this time we'll move forward to the
divisional excellence awards and I'm
very pleased to call dr. Lin temper our
clinical professor of behavioral
sciences it is a pleasure to present
this divisional award in behavioral
science to Lorelei Perez boys both
personally and professionally
distinguished herself by achieving
excellence not only in all the
behavioral science courses that she has
taken but also consistently being
excellent and proficient in our
interpersonal patient communication
skills as well as this personal gift for
her which will continue her education in
psychology Lorelei
thank you
next I would like to introduce to you
dr. David Albert's our director of the
division of community health wow these
are two awards which it's a great
pleasure to give out today there were
many many candidates and many people
over the last year in the last few years
who have worked very hard on public
health cert and Health Services Research
so very impressed with these two
candidates the first award is to Jeffrey
Nicolini and Jeffrey has a sense of
healthcare as a right and slept with a
fill that belief by working to lead and
I mean leave his class in providing care
to the indigent a clinic of student
volunteers in 124 street is not a place
that you typically find students working
on their own but yet Jeffrey and his
classmates should all be compliments as
well work there the clinic will continue
after his departure it is in spy he has
inspired many is an honor to have had
Jeffrey as a student and congratulations
on your award dr. nickel
what community help the set hella for
you don't back into the foot wear
sandals huh in New York
okay dude the next award is pudgy
nacoochee Otto Gina is an exceptional
student with insight and understanding
of Public Health that impressed many in
the department division she developed an
initiative to evaluate seniors at a
community health center the project was
her own initiative she developed the
survey handled the research system in
rascal at Columbia which launched many
faculty members and she did it with
aplomb our dedication to the project was
evident in her many sessions and the
clinic interviewing adults in between
patients that she had in the clinic in a
busy senior year she would always be a
lunch time sitting in the clinic City
with seniors and interviewing them she
was assessing them to see why they used
dental services or don't use dental
services a very important issue with
older seniors she has the skills to
evaluate and work in health services
research and also the concomitant
passion to translate our work into real
real benefit to the population and I
hope she continues her work in public
health and health services research so
dr. ku GRE have been a pleasure to work
with you and
the next individual to come here
represents the endodontics division it
is dr. Jack levy associate clinical
professor of endodontics there is a
power role that tells the following two
ships were near land one leaving and the
other entering the harbor a large crowd
was cheering the outgoing ship and
giving it a hearty send-off scarcely a
person noticed the incoming vessel a
wise man watching the scene commented
rejoiced nod over the ship setting out
the sea for you know not what destiny
awaits it what storms may encounter and
what dangers it may undergo rejoice
rather over the ship that has reached
port safely returning all its passengers
in peace we applaud all the graduates
for having reached the harbour after a
difficult educational voyage in
preparing to dock we wish them health
happiness and satisfaction in their new
careers on behalf of the Department of
endodontics i'm pleased to present the
awards for excellence in root canal
therapy
to quite kejuan Lee for two years of
having reached the highest excellence in
endodontic clinical endodontics I'm
proud to present this award to you to
this data arjona miss Naida has been a
member of the area of endodontic
concentration for two years she helped
as a group member to publish to research
projects she attended a group a table
clinic in Atlantic City and presented
her table clinic on research and she's
been a very committed student in
endodontics and I'm very proud to
present the American Association of
endodontics award to listen a de arjona
I you realize the taking pictures thank
you next time pleased to present someone
whom you've all probably heard about if
you are a parent or an important other
here he is presenting a number of awards
he is our chair for the section of adult
dentistry and the director of one of the
divisions in that section of the
division of operative dentistry he is a
Columbia alum and somebody that
everybody appreciates dr. Richard licked
involved
these awards are for excellence in
restorative dentistry I'm always amazed
how students can come in to the school
and learn this intricate talent so early
and so well it's a testament to their
perseverance and their skill and it's
also a testament to the courage of the
faculty to allow them to go into the
clinic to do that on patients and the
combination seems to work out if the
other a third-year students here yes
these individuals who win these awards
and and coming to the clinic and perform
excellently do so because they know what
it is they're going to do when they come
in they prepare for what they're going
to do before they come in they are
prepared at the chair and they can
proceed with their technical skill with
ease and have the faculty there to guide
them at the end when they need it these
are exceptional people all of our
students perform well clinically these
are excellent the award for divisional
excellence in operative dentistry goes
to erika park jang
eric is going to be a pediatric dentist
right here at calm you know
the Academy of General Dentistry the
outstanding general practitioner award
goes to an individual who worked in the
clinic as though he had been there his
entire life he is talented he's mature
he has a terrific work ethic and we're
going to keep him here for as long as we
can he's going into the AED program here
at called you'd dental Maxime cerebro
we're going to lose this individual to
have it but he'll do very well there me
the Academy of operative dentistry award
goes to jump it Kim
the American Academy of dental practice
administration of foundation award is
for very special individual she's all
things to all people she moves in
terrific circles she gets her work done
she persevered and I'm very proud of
Nina katharine kim
what is this one I'm handing it to you
Oh stay here stay here stay here Nina is
also the winner of the American Academy
of aesthetic dentistry award that award
was a tie the American the second
American Academy of aesthetic dentistry
award goes to kejuan leaf
yeah kewal is going to stay here as well
he's going to do the AE GG program here
what you're doing a lot of implants are
placed in our clinics every year and the
one who placed that the best judged by
our faculty the American Academy of
implant dentistry award goes to richard
panting dela Rosa
Richard is also going to a graduate
program is going to be a pediatric
dentist is going to montefiore hospital
another award for genetic park the
American Academy of osseointegration
award John hick I'm sorry James Young
Danielle what do you said what's gone so
hot we thought um you're staying here
fix another picture
John Young is going to do the plastered
on a program here at College of Dental
Medicine the quintessence award for
clinical achievement and restorative
dentistry is going to a very special
young man who does everything for us
does everything for the members of the
senior class did everything for the
faculty to help them deal with the
senior class it would have been very
difficult to get through the year
without the assistance of this
individual he was wonder in our clinics
he was always cooperative his patients
loved him and soda why the quintessence
of war for clinical achievement
restorative dentistry is Jeremy zuniga
okay I'll be back we'll be back now I'd
like to call up your doctor john erick
representing as the director the
division of oral biology well what is
our biology it's really the basic
sciences which provide the foundation
for what all the clinical disciplines
you're going to see the other awards
given out for and it's its excellence in
courses such as Anatomy or histology
microbiology immunology and we give out
two awards the first award is the
divisional excellence award in rural
biology and the recipient award has dr.
Flavio guitar
the second award isn't worth given by
the American Association of oral
biologists the recipient of this award
is thought is dr. Mary Ballard
and I'd like to bring forth someone that
again was one of my professors although
somehow he looks younger than I do I
don't understand dr. Lewis Mendel
associate dean for extramural hospital
programs and all surgeons par excellence
thank you of course it's an honor for me
to present these awards I'm going to be
presenting seven awards for the division
of oral maxillofacial surgery one of the
rewards that I'm going to get is I think
i'm going to have seven pictures of
myself taken up once that's nice at any
rate the first award for the divisional
excellence award in the oral
maxillofacial surgery goes to stove on
patel
here is an individual whose ability both
academic and technical was recognized
not only by us but by his receiving an
outstanding residency LSU in Shreveport
Louisiana it's an excellent residency so
they recognized his ability just as we
thank you Oh would that decision well
you've gotta take about a second and
it's same together Paul can tell me come
on up there oh you see two awards both
related to pan and then about the
Academy of cranial facial pain award in
the American Academy of oral facial pain
Awards so you get to visit to okay
and the old mention it Paul this the
next award the American Association of
oral maxillofacial surgeons award goes
to marry ballot I need not say anything
about mayor you all have heard about it
for miletti ductility 17 so where are
you married I didn't recognize you Mary
Amanda came up the first time your hair
was down and then of course we have the
American Association of oral
maxillofacial surgeons of the one for
dental implants and articles to Whitney
floor and worthy we were fortunate we're
fortunate to have Whitley stay on with
us for six more years that's a
punishment and there shall be with us as
a resident in oral maxillofacial surgery
and now we pull up the area again near
valid or she could soon why Mary all
right Mary come back you got two awards
the American jeez look at this one
American Dental Society of
anesthesiology Horace Wells award in
oral maxillofacial surgery Mary ballad
stay right there in there and then you
also get the award the New York State
Society of oral and maxillofacial
surgeons Awards so you get two of them
we've got two pictures
now I'm pleased to introduce a professor
about whom you may have heard glowing
reports our professor associate
professor of Radiology get glowing
reports dr. Steven singer I am most
pleased and honored to present the
divisional excellence award in oral and
maxillofacial radiology to Robert
Weinstock dr. Weinstock
and the next award is the American
Academy of oral and maxillofacial
radiology award and that goes to fall
can't help me not only for excellence in
the clinic and in the classroom but also
for outside the classroom where he took
a project upon himself and wrote a
manuscript which was accepted for
publication in quintessence
international coming up the summer
now i'm pleased to present to you
representing the division of
orthodontics dr. satish chandra pi
assistant professor of orthodontics ok
the first award is for divisional
excellent sword in orthodontics to
jacqueline fish
the second award is for the american
association of orthodontists award for
been sorry k modi
now I'm near and dear to my heart and I
have to complement the next figure on
his restraint when all these future
pediatric dentists have been given
Awards he's been very calm about it
representing the division of pediatric
dentistry dr shantanu lal the director
of the predoctoral pediatric dentistry
program guys this was a great year for
predoctoral pediatric dentistry as you
may know we had the highest summer of
applicants and also the best match
results ever this speaks highly of the
sheer talent in this class but it also
makes it harder to recognize just one or
two individuals nevertheless for all her
passion and hard work in pediatric
dentistry the divisional excellent award
goes to and I believe I can say this
doctor or nah Leroy
and for his tremendous work ethic and
efforts with the Academy the American
Academy of pediatric dentistry student
award goes to dr. Richard della Rossa
hey it's now my pleasure to bring up dr.
Daniel Roizman assistant clinical
professor of periodontics representing
the division of paradise a right to
congratulate the entire class of 2010
and all your accomplishments certainly a
job well done the level of education you
receive here at Columbia University with
olives dedicated faculty and staff is
second to none having now been part of
three different mental institutions I
can tell you without any hesitation that
the philosophy and the level of
education that's provided here is the
one I'm most proud to be associated with
ero to this point has been long and I
hope rewarding but your journey as
dentists and as future leaders of the
field is just beginning you'll have good
days and you'll have bad days but I just
want you to keep in mind that your worst
day sometimes as someone else's hope for
best day to the pair of your residents
out there and proud to say we have six
I'd like to wish you luck in your
respective residences and soon you will
discover like the rest of us the
periodontal paradox which is patients
who have the deepest pockets have also
no money so it's not only endemic
through the population in Washington
Heights lastly I want to clarify because
there has been some confusion with why I
stopped signing the completion forms
I have no idea what they were and I hope
you don't tell Dana I still don't on
behalf of the Department of
periodontology i would like to present
the first award division of excellence
in the ward appear domick so dr. Scott
solo
the second award goes to called the
American Academy of proton ecology award
goes to Joseph pains
the third award northeastern society of
periodontics are were appropriate
appropriately goes to someone is going
to Texas and that's miles Mason
that's one last award quintessence award
for clinical achievement and para
Dominic's and a word goes to Jeffrey
Nicolini did we get the shoes but not
like to bring back someone you have
already met but certainly deserves a
recall dr. Lincoln Thal if any of you
know what a case completion is case
completion is one point in your complex
cases and if you don't have
prosthodontics in the case it's not
you're not going to get a complex case
you can argue with dr. evangelina's all
you want but you're not getting maybe
point 125 this is but never a case
prosthodontics is difficult
prosthodontics is done in stages
prosthodontics takes a long time it
involves laboratory work and involves
getting things checked prosthodontics is
hard the end result is terrific if it's
done properly prosthodontics is
difficult
we argued a long time to select the
awardees for prosthodontics there are so
many good clinical students in this
class but the award for divisional
excellence in prosthodontics goes to
John hick kim tran it gently as i said
is going to do a cross-eyed onyx program
at Harvard University the envelope
please thank you very much I'm not sure
what this means but it's very
significant this is the ML best of the
best prosthodontics award I don't know
if they're referring to the student or
to the hallow articulator but it's the
Hannah best of the best process I like
award goes to take an elf arrow
the International Congress of oral
implantology us there actually is an
international congress of oral
implantology as they meet annually and
vote on things the Sullivan the
Sullivans shine award presented by the
International Congress goes to raid T
Joan will wait for this exhibition I'll
give that to rate personally the new
york academy of oral rehabilitation
there is actually also new york academy
of our rehabilitation they meet several
times every year and talk about
rehabilitation
the America the new york academy of oral
rehabilitation award in removable
prosthodontics removable prosthodontics
means you can take it out and put it
back in at your leisure goes to victims
way
made some excellent get a little closer
then your Academy of oral rehabilitation
also gives an award in fixed
prosthodontics as as compared to the
removable prosthodontics one for each
this way called Aug rothschild memorial
award in fixed prosthodontics I didn't
know ugh ow but I I would imagine that
he was he excelled in a fixed price
check ancestry and because of the long
and distinguished career of dr. Roth
child there is a check that goes along
with his award which makes it really
valuable so the youth of the new york
academy of oral rehabilitation ugh of
moral award fixed prosthodontics goes to
Simon bail
I think I'm done here we'll have to call
you back again I think my work thank you
it's my pleasure to recognize it has to
come forward the director of the
division of oral pathology to present
divisional excellence in stomatology
Awards dr. David zigger Ellie thank you
okay now in the division we administer
basically three courses one in oral
pathology roughly 15 hours in length one
in oral cancer about the same in length
15 hours and then a large survey course
roughly 70 hours in the junior year we
force the students to memorize or learn
one way or another about 1.73 kilobytes
of information a lot of facts and the
top three students are the ones i'll be
giving awards to the first one is the
division excellence in stomatology and
that goes to jacqueline efficient
the second award is the work from the
American Academy of oral maxillofacial
pathology and that goes to Emily seed
reesman
and the third award is from the American
Academy of oral medicine and once again
we'll be asking Mary Ballard to come up
here for this in pharmacology and a
superb prosthodontist and many of the
people he cared for were the people who
were down in the theater district and he
was notorious with his pharmacologic
background for having available a free
full bar in the front of the office so
that people were quite relaxed when they
sat down at his dental chair but he was
a superb clinician a very tough
demanding individual and there is an
award in his honor every year and this
year the person who won that award based
on not only superb performance in the
pharmacology course but also research
done and I'd like her to stand to be
recognized new young
congratulations mayor now I'd like to
bring forth someone who has added a
genus across something that that was
really special here is probably the
person mentoring the most students in
research in the institution these days
and it's just a splendid addition to our
faculty dr. Jeremy mal senior associate
dean for research there are many reasons
an extremely proud of the recipient of
contentious award for research
achievement if I'm here to provide you
with all the details of her research
shipment will be here till next Monday
so in the interest of time it's a great
pleasure to present the contentions of
work for research shipment to new ink
this time I'd like to call back to the
podium our vice dean for academic
affairs dr. Moss allenton and it's going
to be no surprise in this event very
honor so many qualities in our graduates
that the highest academic achievement
award which is given by the Alpha Omega
dental fraternity again we had to pick
Mary Mary Ballard dr. Ballard would you
kindly come up again
and now for an award that recognizes
someone often from one half of our group
but not always I'd like to bring to you
dr. Calkins L associate professor of
community although I'm here today to
honor one of you let me extend my
sincere congratulations to all of you
and do very well done I'm delighted to
be here today to present the a AWD
Eleanor J bush ii memorial award this
award was established to recognize a
senior dental student who is an AWD
member and has demonstrated outstanding
leadership and academic excellence the
award this year is to be given to dr.
Jeanne Olivo
the reasons for jeannie's selection are
many indeed in fact at one point I had
prepared a list of all of her many
accomplishments and worthy activities
but I'm going to shorten it simply to
say that Cheney has been active in a
variety of community events student
organizations as well as in research
efforts indeed all of this put together
in one package certainly represents
excellence in academics leadership and
professionalism congratulations Jeannie
I'm very pleased to present you with
this award
Thank You Carol I'd like to just
introduce you to someone who's in our
audience and to make note of the fact
that the New York State Dental
Association has a gift for each of the
seniors note that is not a new car
please we pay dues to these people but
I'd like to introduce dr. Jeffrey sends
her out here who represents them he will
be out there to meet you and greet you
and present you with these gifts when we
are there for the reception at our
conclusion also do want to thank Delta
Dental who has sponsored that reception
out there and I hope you appreciate what
what they're trying to do for us as well
it is my pleasure at this time to give
the next several awards the first is the
American student Dental Association
award our students are so intelligent
that a number of years ago they voted as
a group almost unanimously that all
students should belong and it would be
part of what we collect from them for
activities fees to the American to the
American student Dental Association you
know that we have one president that
received an award today when Stevens was
his predecessor two years ago and
receiving an award as well today this
award is for service through that
organization to someone who has
represented our district extremely well
who will be going for periodontics
advanced education to NYU next year and
I'm very pleased to call forward Amanda
huxton
when I was a student here dr. Lewis
Mandel and dr. George Minervini were the
co-chairs of oral surgery in this
institution George Minervini and who
this in his memory this award is named
was the true raconteur he was always at
the senior dinner dance sort of the
emcee for the evening he had a sense of
humor for an oral surgeon right Lois
that was extraordinary and just a gift
of gab and he knew more jokes than
anybody I ever knew he didn't even need
local anesthesia he got the patients
laughing so much but in his honor we
have an exemplary professional demeanor
award which goes to a pediatric dentist
will train at montefiore hospital
Richard pantic delarosa
the International College of dentists
recognizes a leadership and one of the
people in this class and i think it was
most evident to those of us in
attendance at the senior farewell dinner
dance when he got up and said a few
words that this is a gentleman who is a
quiet leader but is a very clear leader
and is an important emotional part of
this class he is headed for an or a
residency in oral pathology here at
newyork-presbyterian hospital is my
pleasure to give the International
College of dentists leadership award to
Eugene
Pierre foo shark was a French dentist in
gen-pop iliff mal say we said phobia and
he is sort of the father of modern
dentistry he preceded the name that a
lot of you have heard in gb black the
pierre Bouchard academy as an award that
they allow each school to present for
leadership and service and doing things
that make the better institution the
individual who receives this is going to
a GPR at lincoln hospital here in New
York City next year is my pleasure to
give our yearbook co-editor ginamarie
cachoeira the Pierre Bouchard Academy
Award
you may wonder where that toothbrush
came from several years ago there's a
tradition of Columbia at the main or
south campus as some of us would rather
call it that at that moment everywhere
every school when they're introduced for
their degrees throw something the
business school throws monopoly money
journalism shredded newspapers we used
to throw toothbrushes but I suddenly
realized you're going to put somebody's
eye out with that thing so we brought
these large toothbrushes the Dean
doesn't know what the plot is but
they're going to try to get down to the
Today Show and stand in line or outside
the window waving these some of our
students were on the front page of the
New York Times with those toothbrushes
several years ago so it's become quite
their tradition I just keep reminding
them very fragile you have seen the
excellence that is our student body here
these individuals in spite of their
youth have worked extremely hard
extremely well and have done the right
thing something that we all question
does it happen from this day and age it
certainly has happened with them their
futures are bright they will all give us
big huge checks someday for the alumni
fund and I again invite you all out to
have a reception with us out here in the
Fourier outside this and gun saw help me
da dan Yvonne che che gracias merci and
thank you
oh I have excuse me I've made an error
here we have something a little
different this year this is the second
person that the class invited to speak
you didn't mean to leave this off we
have as you know group leaders in our
senior practice program this is one of
our group leaders she has not been at
this position the longest of that group
but she has clearly been one of those
has had the most impact on this class in
particular it's my pleasure to belatedly
introduce dr. Jessica Hill burger which
remarks ok ok movie thanks dr. Davis hi
everybody so I just first want to say I
was in touch with dr. Avenged elitist
and she sends her congratulations and
her very best wishes to all of you and
your families and friends so you guys
know how to have a good time you know
how to dance that was a lot of fun the
other night congratulations class of
2010 special congratulations to today's
award winners well thank you for asking
me to speak today I think most of you
know how much I can talk so I hope I'm
not repeating myself as I address you
here what do I want to tell you i want
to tell you to be able to sleep at night
as I hope for my own children I hope
that you have a life that allows you to
do that a life where your days are spent
in a profession that will fulfill you I
know it may not feel like that right now
in fact I think that PTSD or
post-traumatic dental school disorder
can take a while to get over but you
will get over it and then you'll realize
that you really do enjoy working with
your hands and helping people among
other things like the ones you said at
your interview about four and a half
years ago and you'll realize that you
have learned to be a professional I hope
you'll be the kind of professional that
can sleep at night because you know that
you did the best that you could for your
patience that your understanding why
you're doing what you're doing that
you're a lifelong learner and will
continue broadening your knowledge base
as you grow
and that you care about your patients
your families your friends and
yourselves you can sleep at night
because you conduct yourselves
truthfully and honestly and even if
things do not go as planned you can cope
and figure out a new direction you will
not be perfect no one is you will make
mistakes we all do learn from them and
try not to make the same one as more
than once try not to be confused and
frustrated when you come across what
seemed to be conflicting opinions just
as I'm sure you found in clinic not all
dentists think alike no that one of us
is not the right one and that the others
are wrong there are usually choices what
we all hope is that we have taught you
to think of these options consider them
present them eloquently to your patients
and choose the course you are most
comfortable with don't think there's
only one way to do something especially
as you progress in your careers your
lives and encounter new challenges you
have been so much fun to share bc seven
with i love talking about dentistry
practice management my children you your
lives shopping houses relationships and
most of all maybe my hair I wish all of
you the lives that you hope for Thank
You class of 2010 for the privilege of
addressing you today and congratulations
and that's why they love it please join
us out in the lobby thank you
you